So we've talked about visual cues to encode and represent
your data. Another thing we consider is the different types
of data that are available. Most data can be categorized
into 3 basic types. In fact, we've seen all 3
types of this data during our walk through of the
baseball data without explicitly referring to them as such. The
first of these types is numeric data. Numeric data as
you might expect, is any data where our data points
are exact numbers. These data have meaning as
a measurement such as a baseball player's height
or weight or as a count, such as number of hits or home runs for a player
or how many players there are on a
team. Statisticians also might call numerical data, quantitative data.
Numerical data can be characterized into discrete or
continuous data. Discrete data has distinct values whereas continuous
data can assume any value within a range. For
example, a player's number of home runs would be
a discrete data set. You can only have discrete
whole number values like 10, 25, or 34. A
player cannot for example, hit 14.375 home runs. A
player either hits a home run or he doesn't.
On the other hand, continuous data are numbers that
can fall anywhere within a range. Like a player's
batting average which falls between 0 and 1000. So
a player could have a batting average of 0.250, they
could also have a batting average of 0.357 or
0.511. And so again just to hammer this home, examples
of numeric data might be a baseball player's height
or weight or their number of home runs or a
number of hits or a number of doubles. The
take away here is that this is data that are
numbers and they are not ordered in
time. They're just numbers that we've collected.